libertarians have often been divided on
intellectual property or kind of unclear
is intellectual property something that
is like owning regular property a real
property that you know it's a piece of
land that you can take and subdivide and
sell to whoever you want and then
certain rights in here in that or is it
actually a short term or a limited term
government-granted monopoly on a stream
of revenue or ownership rights that go
to something that you make whether it's
a patent or a copyright the progress
Clause of the United States Constitution
grants Congress the authority to promote
the progress of science and the useful
arts by securing for limited times to
authors and inventors the exclusive
right to their respective writings and
discoveries this was a big deal during
the Constitutional Convention I guess
brink why don't you start is you know is
that the beginning and end of the
argument for intellectual property
patent and copyright just that the
government grants it for a limited
period of time and that's all we should
be talking about well I don't think for
libertarians
so just the genius of the term
intellectual property should not be
underestimated it's like the best Savion
marketing ploys since about well
predates the death tax but when you when
you have a term like that that just
stacks the debate in your favor then
good for whoever comes up with that and
so the term intellectual property
immediately puts free-market ourian
Servat ins and libertarians disposed
towards well I like property right so I
must like this but just because you can
create tradable property rights in
something doesn't necessarily mean it's
a good idea to do that you have tradable
property rights and taxi medallions we
don't think that's a good idea
while are we and we don't mistake it for
something that a you know a Lockean
property that you know the taxicab
driver found in nature and then added
his sweat and now on to tax right and of
course once upon a time we had property
rights of human beings and they were
defended zealously as part of the sacred
institution of property and we don't
think that's a good idea so but in the
case of intellectual property the idea
is to take this Lockean notion of how
unknown
property unknown physical property
becomes owned by mixing your labor with
it and applying that to the realm of
ideas the problem is that's just I think
a massive category error because the
Lockean notion is about how to create
rights and previously unknown property
nobody thinks that just mixing your
labor with stuff you don't own in
somebody else owns turns it into your
stuff so Auto Workers take you know
steel and glass and rubber and turn into
cars they mix their labor with it
doesn't make it theirs
right thus the stuff was owned by the
auto company and the car is owned by the
auto company so the mere fact that you
that you come up with an idea doesn't
then create property rights in
previously owned physical property which
is what a bunch of what actually is
happening that you are basically
creating control rights over property
you can't use your property to copy my
invention or my book or my record and so
that is I think just a real inversion of
the Lockean notion of natural rights in
property Eli do you want to speak to the
question no there is no question that
copyright and patent has led to some
forms of progress right yeah I think
that's right um you know I come at this
as a libertarian not not a natural
rights libertarian not as an axiomatic
libertarian so so there are people who
come from that tradition who have argued
on both sides of intellectual property
right who who have axiomatically
reasoned that property in intellectual
property rights are completely invalid
and that they or that they should be
permanent and lasts forever and so
that's not how I come at it I come at it
as much more just like an average guy on
the street with a couple different
intellectual builders just an average
guy on the street we'll have any degrees
do yeah so but just with a couple
intellectual filters right so one I
think one thing that I think
libertarians know that other people
don't
is public choice right that when
government starts handing out goodies
like people are going to start
manipulating the political environment
in order to get more of them and the
other thing I think libertarians know
that that maybe the average guy on the
street doesn't know is spontaneous order
right that no no top-down control over
innovation sometimes works so both both
of those filters push the optimal amount
of IP in the direction of less IP but it
doesn't mean that you should completely
abolish it necessarily
it just means less than probably what we
what we have here can we end up can
somebody on the panel remind us of what
was the term what was the copyright term
when the Constitution was written and
what is it now it was 14 years
originally right and it could be
renewable ones once Nobel Prize and now
it is like the author Plus 70 years or
for a corporate copyright at San Jose or
something yeah so and Sasha is that part
of the problem that these terms have
gone from you know being limited which
Constitution talks about to effectively
being unlimited because as Eli was
talking about you know every time Mickey
Mouse every time a couple of different
major properties come up for being fed
into the public domain
something happens under the copyright
term gets extended yet again for sure I
mean there always has to be a starting
point and we have to give the cookie for
innovation and knowing that you did a
good job and therefore you should get
some protection but continually
extending it we inhibit ingenuity we
inhibit progress we inhibit what the
Constituent essentially asks of the
population to continue to create to
continue to better yourself and to
continue the progress of innovation
literature maps if you want to get down
there the general sciences and it just
is incredibly problematic you don't can
anybody talk a little bit like
specifically what is the damage I mean
there's a question we should get to this
of whether or not is it true that
progress you know needs copyright or
would people right would people invent
with people innovate without it I could
talk to that a little bit I and I think
the the evidence is I think most
inventions have are not under patent I
mean most inventions occurred on their
own so
that's a sort of interest and innovate
you know a spur to innovation or not is
a legitimate question you have people
doing these things on their own and some
of the like Heidi Miller she just won
the MacArthur award she's done a lot of
interesting work looking at the human
genome and when you're patenting that
and she actually found that it there's a
inhibit you know the patent inhibited
innovation because there were fewer that
I think 35% fewer follow-ons to Solara
which is the one she's looked at so I
think there's plenty of evidence now and
that's embedded in that it's also
because maybe copy may be copyright and
patent are very different right because
they're dealing with different types of
innovations or different types of
technologies but you know you look at
your job so when I think about this
question I always think of Wikipedia
right this is something that doesn't
work at all in theory but it works in
practice so you have no protection for
contributions that people make a really
significant contributions of putting in
a lot of time writing researching and so
on and it's the biggest encyclopedia
that the world has ever seen it's the
online encyclopedia that anyone can edit
anybody can edit and you know it's
pretty good evidence that we we would
get that sort of and certainly people
talk a lot about in the fields of
fashion and cuisine there are no
intellectual property rights and there
is massive amounts of innovation and
it's all based on kind of what you were
talking about of using and ripping off
copying knocking off change and
meanwhile the overwhelming majority of
copyrighted books and records copyright
is completely irrelevant to them so
ninety-eight percent of all records or
whatever TVs whatever released now are
sell under five thousand copies which
means nobody has copying them you know
what I thought you weren't going to
bring up the sales figures of the
Declaration of Independence about that
bad Welch and I won't thank you that
there aren't good stats on median book
sales but for business books I found
stats only sixty two out of a thousand
business books sell more than five
thousand but here's this very quickly
and then we'll come to
but you know is a publisher you know is
Macmillan is the Simon and Schuster
are they going to publish books the way
that they publish without copyright
protection so again if there's if 98 99
percent of all published material
nobody ever copies because the demand
for it is so small then yes the vast
majority of now copyrighted works would
I think continue to have the same market
you wouldn't have the the mass-market
recording artists you might not have the
CGI blockbusters although these days
they're so stacked towards the opening
weekend that you there is more scope for
getting in there and getting your money
before somebody comes you which
interestingly goes back to 19th century
publishing roots where American authors
would publish first in England and get
money there and then bring it back to it
I just want to clarify I'm not an
abolitionist i but I think this this
aura of sacred property rights needs to
be deconstructed so we can talk about
this just in terms of consequences good
good or real I mean we have a problem
we're not talking about copyright per se
but we need to realize I don't think
it's been talked about as unpublished
works you don't need to notice you don't
need to register registration is only if
you decide to litigate you don't you can
have your book be in the public because
it used to be that way I did not use the
1976 but that's because we had to
coincide with international law and we
had United had to kind of come to the
same elevate point as everybody else
so I don't necessarily think the
copyright conversations just they be on
copyright in the text itself but the
idea published and unpublished works can
you others iconic troves of information
that can be digitized and shared in
access but but people can't do it
because they don't know who owns the
copyright and so it just okay I was
going to ask like what are some of the
specific harms that we can say are being
inflicted by current copyright and
that's certainly one of them all of
these movies recordings books where it's
not clear who owns the copyright so
nobody is going to go in and just
republish them and they are stuck with
orphan works
and back in June the Copyright Office
released a statement how we could
possibly handle orphan works and no
one's brought it up and the issue with
them is there have been suggestions that
we kind of have a government-owned
registrar list of orphan works you can
go and you can claim it and you get 35
years
I don't quote me on that exactly but
that's a big issue we have right now and
with the extension of copyright what do
you do with these works just floating
around to the ether right and then there
are cases where many of you may be
familiar with the movie It's a Wonderful
Life how many of you have seen that how
many of you think that that was a
Christmas classic from the time that it
was released yeah it actually wasn't it
was it went into the public domain in
the late sixties early 70s and a band
because it was free a bunch of local TV
stations picked it up and started
running it because they could and that's
when it was a bomb when it came out
originally and so that's an example of
where having works in the public domain
or not under copyright actually you know
we were able to get real value out I
think another specific harm is that
people are now using copyright law to do
things completely unrelated to
protecting works such as a protecting
firmware on cell phones protecting
firmware on garage door openers and so
on to prevent sort of compatibility just
on using your devices so it's a theory
that you can't you can't you know work
on your own car or truck or you can't
take it to an independent garage because
the software is owned by gian you can't
talk a little bit about this of and this
is where it also slides over into patent
where patent terms have not been
extended it to the same extent that
copyright terms but they've been applied
to more and more types of activities
what are the problems with that so the
so patents they provide an innovation
benefit they raise the returns for
certain kinds of innovations but they
also impose a cost on downstream
innovators because almost all
innovations are based on the
recombination of the pre-existing ideas
and if your access to those pre-existing
ideas is more expensive because of
patents then then the downstream
innovation is inhibited and
over the past you know quarter century
the costs of patent law have been
skyrocketing primarily by the expansion
of patent protection into very vaguely
defined areas like business methods and
software so with chemicals and with
pharmaceuticals the boundaries of the
property right are clearly delineated by
a chemical formula so everybody knows
what's infringing and what isn't
the boundaries for for a software patent
are described in this very abstract
language there's jillian's of them so it
would take basically several lifetimes
to just go through and read all the
patent literature to know whether you're
infringing and then you still wouldn't
know because it's very so yeah does that
actually frees people at are they like a
[ __ ] it let's just do it and we'll see
what happens yeah in Silicon Valley
there's a lot of people who a lot of
companies who forbid their engineers
from researching whether a particular
innovation is patented already because
willful infringement actually you have
to pay treble damages so that is part of
the whole purpose of others my closing
yes because then everybody can learn
from it that's part of that's why we
want you know that and there's
definitely venture capital money that
says I will not touch anything that has
an IP risk associated with it so it does
have a chilling effect let's talk a
little bit about this in an
international context the trans-pacific
partnership the twelve countries that
are dealing with that have you know they
said okay we've got the deal now we're
going to go back to our respective
countries a big part of that a
particularly among libertarians in the
u.s. is like we want to see what the IP
stuff is in that you know how is it good
is it bad how does IP play in an
international context as opposed to a
purely domestic regime so it the case
for extending it to less developed
countries is even weaker than the case
for the status quo here because at least
here we have a sizable community of
copyright and patent holders that have
some benefit from it whereas a less
developed country it's just by imposing
us-style law where they don't have a lot
of IP hold rights holders then basically
what you are negotiating is just a
straight-up wealth transfer from those
countries
to the United States and under the
theory that over the long term if you
have IP law then that will encourage
innovation in a generation or two from
now you'll have lots of patent holders
and copyright holders and you'll benefit
too but but in the for the foreseeable
future is just a straight-up loss for
the countries consent it's essentially
raising the cost that they're doing it
and I found that the IP status quo is
actually bad for innovation then it's
actually retarding the day that these
countries will will converge with us
technological yeah so the US has some of
the strongest IP law in the world and so
we're making other countries for
instance retro actively extend their
their copyright terms and to me like
retroactive extension is the most
corrupt thing we could do to copyright
ever and we're making other countries do
that too in order to be you know get
access to our market is is piracy I mean
this is what you always hear whether
it's from the recording industry or from
you know various types of patent and
copyright holders you know is
international cop copyright and patent
piracy is that actually a problem or is
that just kind of big corporate hype in
the United States especially I guess in
the European Union no it's not an issue
they've got stricter laws and we do they
respect court not slate respect but
obviously they had different write
schemes and we have they have something
called moral rights I mean over there no
China Southeast Asia and so on and so
forth it is somewhat of an issue but
it's also different context of how they
interpret international property you've
country like India heavily influenced by
graver in so there are going to be kind
of in line to the United States and
large schemes but even then they have
new colleges set up the teaches
specifically pads how to patent how to
invent what do you do with it so I think
the pots are to get to your question I
think piracy is an issue but I think yes
it's blown out her portion into the
clouds I think when you when you look at
piracy and and basically it just goes
back to you know
I pee in general we talk about it you
know as you say we enshrine it as
intellectual property but in the
Constitution is basically a statutory
grant to Congress to create a regulatory
regime and today we are living under it
and like any other regulation I think it
has to be evaluated in terms of costs
and benefits and when you look at what
they're doing in terms of protecting you
know you know stopping online piracy
some of the the things SOPA PIPA parts
of the DMCA are so horrendous and and so
overreaching that if you put it in a
cost-benefit analysis I think the costs
far outweigh any the benefit you get
when I think about piracy I always think
about how different industries are
responding to the Internet right because
the Internet is what's enabling all this
piracy and so I think about three
different industries think about
journalism music and video right and in
journalism I think they're they'd
actually gotten the balance kind of
right they you know something like the
New York Times has a paywall but it's
very porous it's very easy to get
through and they sort of just accept
some level of piracy as a way of doing
business and and getting the word out
about their articles maybe someone will
like get through the paywall but then
they'll tweet about the article and
that's good for them so so they don't
worry about it so much and I think that
they're like the most advanced in terms
of how they deal with it and music is
lagging and then film is like way behind
although and I think Brent was talking a
little bit about this I mean the way
that movie industries big movie
industries release video of release
films now they do worldwide same weekend
releases because then there's no need to
pirate or you you minimize that I mean
kim.com the kind of renegade of ANZAC
freakazoid you know wonderful
he's got the ultimate Twitter feed but
he talked about how like you know if if
the movie studio is just started doing
that there would be no reason really to
pirate in many ways well let's let to
wrap it up and then we'll throw it out
to the to the audience you know it
questions about intellectual property
always hinge on techno
I mean when it becomes easy enough to
copy something or to spread it around it
happens and then some you know the law
will try to stop and stop and stop it
and then it will you know the business
will come up with a model that makes
sense of it you know so Napster people
get put in jail and then you have
Spotify or Pandora you know at 10 or 20
years later are we living through a
period and just give a quick answer and
then we'll throw it out you know are we
living through an era where technology
is actually disassembling IP and is that
enough or do we need an intellectual
direction in this I think I think
copyright is sustainable in an Internet
world insofar as it's focused on on
stopping commercial exploitation of
copyrighted con so you can shut down
movie theaters that are showing pirated
versions of your film you can shut down
record companies that are making bootleg
copies you can do that but this a happy
and quest to shut down private
non-commercial copying and sharing I
think is is completely hopeless and and
this interpretation by the copyright
holders that they own this property
event anybody doing anything that they
don't authorize is theft
just puts them in this terrible position
of considering their customers their
enemies and it leaves them today it
works so well for Metallica right
they're the biggest band in the world so
I think that it just breeds a really
unhealthy mindset on the part of the
industry that they are in this
oppositional attitude towards towards
not only their customers but towards all
new technology so they you know the
copyright interests fought the VCR lost
in the Supreme Court just by one vote is
five to four that the bay but we still
are pending bought YouTube we're still
pointing out absence on blank recording
meat right but now it's this easy as
ever broad to to do it privately in
these interim kind of lawsuits against
random you know private individuals
they're just they're just awful and they
accomplish nothing Wayne I would say the
technology has played an interesting
role in in how we look at patents and
copyright and different industries have
different technologies and when I think
one of the fundamental problems we have
when we wrestle with this every year you
know it comes up into Congress they have
this big fight usually nothing gets
resolved then it goes away a few years
they try it again
but I don't think it's a
one-size-fit-all system anymore there's
there's there should be different
approaches for different industries
where these things are different value
and I think you have to sort of get much
more granular in the way you look at
these so what's an example of an
industry that should have stricter IP
and one that detention of weaker well
III think that machinery in general like
like this the stuff of Ford and they you
know what's what's happening with
copywriting the chips inside the cars
versus say say music industry protecting
what's on a CD those kinds of things and
then if you get into the chemical world
can it like like you said the the number
of patents revolving around a chemical
is basically the chemicals in the
formula so it's a pretty small set of
issues that you have to deal with and
trying to cram that into the same issue
as Samsung versus Apple with hundreds of
thousands of patents I just don't think
it what your question about will the
internet make all this go away for
patents so for patents for sure not
because the patent so the internet is
being fed by the software explosion and
the patent explosion is being fed by
software patents so but for NACA right
maybe it's going in a different
direction so but and now we've gotten to
the point where big companies are buying
just huge patent portfolios just to
defend themselves
the majority sixty seventy percent of
patent infringement cases are brought by
trolls so they are brought by companies
that didn't invent anything against
companies that innovate I think it's
going to be really interesting once 3d
printers get better and and 3d chemical
printers because then you're talking
about things that used to be patentable
are just going to be bits of you know
ones and zeros that are going to go
around the world there's as easily as an
mp3 does and enforcement costs are going
to get really high and you know
enforcement costs are costs and we
should you know for thinking about it as
iconic Lee we should consider those
costs and probably we should do less
enforcement at some point if as that so
do you think that'll be kind of I mean
will the people who create new things
that are going to be pirated but for
lack of a better term by 3d printing
how will they recoup their expenses so
you know a band say a band that could
longer sell records because people don't
buy records anymore they go on tour more
do you have a sense of what chemical
companies by the pharmaceutical Congress
might yeah I think I think there are
different models think Fame is a you
know a motivator
I think patronage you know a lot of my
work as you know as a nonprofit person
you know I do work and I give it away
for free but I have a patron you know
the course that air sports everybody
it's worth every penny and not a penny
more maybe and but I have a patron at
the Mercatus and there's my patron and
they and I suspect to then it might be a
service model because you know if you're
3d printing an organ and you're using
like a hand-me-down file and your liver
is kind of bleeding out of your side you
might want to be able to get a custom
design yeah they got some design
services or something okay slasher kind
of tough question but I'm looking at my
six thousand feet point of view as
technology evolves public consciousness
evolves so I think it's very
short-sighted of us to start throwing
our hands up in the air and panicking
and st. leave it to the courts you know
Congress look at behind it things of
that sort I just don't see why we can't
his ad CDs don't sell Pandora media
suddenly becomes the next popular thing
now suffice in the marketplace five
years ago I know as far as I was and I'm
the quote unquote millennial generation
so I think if we give up now and we
start really hammering gel and we start
freaking out at this point in time we're
going to inhibit innovation I think it's
a big mistake so I see technology
actually aiding the public consciousness
aiding everyone in this room to see
what's the next big thing how can we
kind of work around this issue and then
go back and improvement by the
legislature
you